Now that you filled in the section
headings of your master
resume spreadsheet, begin to fill out
the content within each section area.
Within each section,
you showcase your experience
with bullet pointed statements.
So, what does a good bullet
point statement look like?
A strong bullet statement
starts with an action verb.
Use a variety throughout your resume.
A strong bullet point statement avoids
using pronouns and small words.
For example, instead of, I built the
toaster, use the phrase, built toaster.
This keeps your statement concise,
consistent, and direct.
Strong bullet point
statements are concise.
These should be a maximum of one and
a half lines each.
They also include concrete and
numerical evidence to show
the impact of your work.
Noting achievements and
accomplishments makes a resume shine.
How can you creatively transfer your
experience into concise bullet points?